first game of a four-game series
against the toronto blue jays angels in
dunedin florida
and that is the spring training site for
the toronto blue jays
it's a good veteran lineup that ross
stripling will face for a second
start of the season he lasted just three
and a third innings versus the yankees
that was on saturday when he allowed
three runs on
seven hits he had trouble finding that
good curveball that he needs to get
batters out this is shohei ohtani who is
the d.h for the angels oh tony off to a
good start batting 300 or knee or they
going
swinging to miss another off speed
pitcher tiny never really picked it up
and stripling has his first
strikeout of the game five for seven in
his career versus ross stripling with
two home runs for travel do we make it
16.
he's going to say they got 60. do we
make it extra bases you bet as it
trickles into the corner
trout easily with the slide into second
mike trout with his second double of the
year trout with that double is now
six for eight with two home runs against
ross
stripley trout now who's at second base
so the batter
is anthony rendon rolls to the right
side in the hole for a base hit
butterfield
one to nothing oh yes anthony rendon is
just fine
and this is a little slider on the outer
half and a great at-bat by rendon goes
right with it hits it where nobody's at
angel's first two hits both the other
direction on ross stripling
and they put a run on the board trout
scores easily from second base
a big two out hit right there for
anthony rindon angels with a one-nothing
lead biggio moves up to second now two
outs in the inning and hey oscar
hernandez is the battery
there's a base hit that's going to score
a run vizio's around third he'll come in
to score
and another two out base hit rendon did
it for the angels in the top half
pay oscar hits a 02 basic to
right center and it's a tie game one to
one you
win silver slugger awards by being a
tough out comes up with a big hit to
tight driving home kamen bizio
[Applause]
[Applause]
for his second home run of the season
and the blue jays have scored three in
the bottom of the first to take a 3-1
lead
telling you they were flirting with
danger
up in the strike zone against vladimir
guru i don't care if you were just
trying to
show him that pitch you are flirting
with danger when you've got a guy who
can hit the ball
to all fields with that kind of power
so the next batter is iglesias a base
hit could mean a run
and here's the first pitch on jose and
he rips one into left field and that is
going to mean a run
just getting to it is the left fielder
guriel coming in and scoring is
upton and the angels have a runner at
second back-to-back doubles a run on the
board and now the
lead for the blue jays slice to a run
it's 3-2
so here's fowler breaking ball lifted
into shallow center gritshit broke back
he's got a hassle and he makes a heck of
a play
randall grichik saw the big swing broke
back and then had to hustle makes a
diving play to retire next to fowler so
the batter now
is david fletcher hit could still tie up
the game it's 3-2 toronto in the second
that one shot to the right side toward
the corner it goes and it's down contact
is king for that man it's an rbi it's a
two run inning two out rbis
oh they hurt the opposing team just
putting the ball
in play fletch do what he does best
really making you upset as a pitcher you
think you make a pitch he makes contact
slices out with right field picks up
another double angel's able to tie this
game up
at three so the hitter now is shohei
ohtani who struck out his first time
up by guerrero i got ahead of myself
if he doesn't catch that ball the angels
take the lead that was a nice play by
guerrero who's playing first base this
season
so that the plate is joe panic left that
one out over the plate
ranging to his left fletcher recovers
bare-handed
puts it all together my goodness what a
fine athletic play
yeah fletch you know he loves the game
he's always smile but he can slow the
game down
as well that's a tough play hop on him
he still
does not panic against joe connor
he makes the play crowded double in two
times up
here's the pitch and mike trout swings
at that one and drills a ball deep into
left center field
it is trout of here
boy he hit that one out of sight there
against stripling
trout has been on fire that's home run
number three of the season
and that will give the angels a 4-3 lead
the angels lead it 4-3 trout three
career home runs against this man one up
one away
kevin biggios oh for one with a walk and
a run
scored it'll be the next batter swinging
to drive high fly ball to right field
power looking up this one's gonna go
home run kevin bizio his second
of the season and the blue jays have
tied it up
they're never out of it because of the
threat of the home run
and that they have that ability to do
that and kevin vigil is going to tie
this one up
two-seam fastball out over the plate and
you can see with that nice little
uppercut swing kevin
with his second home run second rbi of
the season
two that's righty guerrero had a two run
home run his first time up deep to
center field
he's batting with bushette at second
another breaking ball base hit past
fletcher in the right center
here comes bow around third and he'll
score
well you talk about a young hitter
making an adjustment from pitch to pitch
that was terrific oh boy
was it after watch how he cuts the swing
down
slaps that ball the other way now the
angels need a two-out hit shohei otani
will be
the batter swings at that one and lines
the ball into right field that's going
to fall in for a base hit fowler scores
ohtani delivers with two outs an rvi
single and this game is tied up once
again it's 5-5
angels have runners now at first and
second
two outs here in the top of the ninth in
a five-five game
and now mike trout is going to have a
say as far as this game is concerned
[Applause]
and richard makes another terrific play
randall grichik broke on contact
[Applause]
third walk issued by angel's pitching
looks like we're going to have a
pinch runner come into the ball game for
teles and that's
jonathan davis there's a pick-off toss
and the pinch runners picked off the bag
that wasn't even
close right there wow they brought him
in to run for teles and he gets picked
off to
end the inning so we are headed to the
10th second and third
two outs in a five-five game and
fletcher hits a fly ball into shallow
center that's gonna drop in for a base
hit
the angels will score one the angels
will score
two and david fletcher shows some magic
with that bat again for the angels he's
had a three rbi
night and the angels have a 7-5 lead
the blue jays are down to their final
out in this ball game angels need one
more out
that will do it guess who's five and two
the angels off to an amazing start this
year
they head out on the road they are
victorious